what's going on guys this is rob and i
can't find my geek culture explained hat
i feel naked without it
wait i know where it is
okay
i found my hat
i'm not me when i don't have my hat okay
do we have some news for you guys in
this episode we've got some news
involving the daredevil show on disney
plus
apparently everybody's talking about
galactus now but before we get into that
a couple things one uh i'm probably
going to be looking at hiring somebody
for the room around them i love making
this show for you guys but i also want
to be able to focus on stuff on the back
end on like growing the geek culture
explained brand so i'm looking at the
idea of hiring a host not doing it right
now but just something to keep in the
back of your mind for future reference
because you may see somebody new here on
the channel but for those of you guys
who want to avoid spoilers for venom 2
be sure to just kind of skip ahead in a
little time stamp that we have which
will take you to the next little segment
here having said that as most of you
guys know with the post-credits scene on
venom
it's kind of huge right venom is now in
the marvel cinematic universe this is a
big deal here with that being the case
the one question everybody's asking here
is when is venom going to meet
spider-man it's the one thing that we
all want to see and truth to tell
previously it was one of these things we
just kind of assumed somewhere along the
line the venom would end up in the mcu
we didn't really know how we didn't
definitively know if it would actually
happen so in reality the question of
whether or not venom would beat
spider-man was really more of just fan
wishful thinking with a post-credits
scene on venom 2 now we know it's going
to happen the funny thing about this
though is that andy circus's answer is
still kind of the same answer that it
was before that they want to focus on
the venom verse and they want to bring
in spider-man at a future point in time
in reality this is the smartest decision
to make because one of the big issues
that venom 2 stands to run into here is
that its post credit scene could
actually overshadow the movie that
nobody talks about the plot of venom 2
nobody talks about carnage or anything
like that instead they focus on the
post-credits scene admittedly there's
room for that right because if we're
being honest with ourselves when you
compare the post-credits scene to the
overall venom film it kind of feels like
venom 2 was made and the movie's there
but nothing in the movie is important in
comparison to the post-credits scene
right it's not like anything happens in
the film that ties into the post-credits
scene and gives us the reason to connect
the two instead it's just kind of a fun
movie where some crazy stuff happens and
there probably should have been more
bloody guts than there was and then we
get the post-credits scene and now
everybody's talking about spider-man and
venom so having said that when andy
circus had his discussion with the hero
nation podcast and was talking about how
they wanted to focus on the venomverse
given the nature of the post-credits
scene this really begs a lot of
questions right because remember one of
the things the symbiote told eddie brock
is that the symbiote share a hive mind
stretched over what is it something like
80 billion years across universes so
they're a multiversal concept and for
comic book fans who are familiar with
the venom mythos this has given rise to
a discussion about null the symbiote god
now is nola symbiote god too much to
throw into a singular movie yes right
the introduction of null was more of a
crossover it involved a lot of stuff
going on now in all honesty if they
tried to invoke null with regards to the
larger symbiote mythos they could do it
by leaving out a bunch of things that
led into it into the comics right the
codices and all that kind of stuff
absolute carnage and so on and so forth
and just kind of go directly into it for
those of you guys who don't know who
null is he's a recent creation during
the donnie kate's run on venom and
basically what it revealed to us is that
the symbiotes are basically living
darkness right if darkness could take a
physical form they'd be called the
living abyss and noah basically created
them as a means to expand his sphere of
influence across really the whole
multiverse as well as destroy the
celestials the reason being is because
null existed really before anything
existed he existed what was called the
void of emptiness and the idea here is
that once the celestials kind of entered
into this void and filled it with what
we now call the universe it pissed nol
off so we ended up in a war with the
celestials managed to kill one of them
he was basically defeated by the others
created the all-black necro sword in the
process the sword you're going to see
gore using in the new thor movie but
this was important because in turn after
creating the living abyss he was
basically trapped inside of a planet
that was more or less composed of
symbiotes and then following that the
symbiotes went forward and basically
became what were called space nights in
the sense that they would bond
themselves to different hosts and they
would really operate as protectors venom
was the first significant deviation away
from that because more often than not
the symbiotes took on the character
traits of the people they bonded to but
because eddie brock had a hatred of
peter parker because peter cost him his
job and because the venom symbiote was
initially bonded to peter parker as
spider-man and was then cast off by
peter parker and webb of spider-man
number 45 the venom symbiote hated
spider-man and so basically in that
shared hatred when eddie and venom
bonded to each other they actually
deviated away from what the symbiotes
are normally supposed to be and really
became the first kind of villainous
symbiote that we're aware of in marvel
comics that's really the real important
thing about the character of them having
said that the idea of introducing null
in the venom verse essentially as the
person who's responsible for having
created the symbiotes this could be done
in a wide array of different forms would
he be on the same level of power as noah
that we're familiar with in the comics
probably not if anything his role as
being the creator of the symbiotes would
be more ceremonial than anything else
right kind of the father of the
symbiotes and that would basically be it
whether it was done through
technological means or just sheer
reality warping powers which is what
null was able to do we won't really know
but it is a cool concept and i do love
the idea of what sony's doing here and
especially the way that andy circus
explained it and simply saying that yes
spider-man's there yes spider-man and
venom are going to meet but what they
don't want to do is take away from what
could be a very compelling arc involving
tom hardy and the venom symbiote and
somebody just give us spider-man because
we all know once that threshold gets
crossed once spider-man meets venom
unless they do something phenomenal with
the character of venom following that
throwing him on new avengers or
something like that he's gonna be one of
those characters just gonna kind of fall
to the wayside because we're gonna get
what we wanted which was spider-man
meeting venom a lot of people want to
see spider-man get the venom symbiote
which would be even cooler but still you
know it's smart that they're buying
their time they're smart that they
recognize yes people want to see
spider-man and venom meet
so let's kind of drag that out a little
bit and just kind of give them some cool
stories so they can kind of build up the
anticipation to that particular thing
but as we normally do here kind of
deviating away from comic book movies
and all that kind of stuff for a second
let's talk about video games and what
may turn out to be one of the most
controversial moves that's happened in
recent years so those of you guys who
are big in the video game community
specifically metal gear solid silent
hill you guys know those games are
released by konami and there was a very
public parting between konami and hideo
kojima which a lot of people saw that
it's just kind of like okay so like
basically konami's dead
and the reason why is because while
konami had released games outside of the
metal gear franchise with hodeo kojima
and even looking at silent hill
different things like that truth to tell
metal gear solid was the bread and
butter of konami right any time that
game was announced people flocked to the
stores to buy it and they bought it in
droves now in reality while hideo kojima
does have a fan base i kind of feel in a
lot of ways their fan base is louder and
they seem bigger than they actually are
but the important thing to take away
from that is his fan base was hard
core and so when hideo kojima left a lot
of his fans went with him now in an
effort to keep the metal gear solid
franchise alive konami
against any
logic or reason
gave us a game called metal gear
survivor which everyone hated they
despised that game and it was bad
rightfully so it was bad it was a metal
gear zombie game and it's every bit as
terrible as you think it is right it
might even be worse than you imagine it
being the reason why i run over this
kind of brief history between konami and
hideo kojima is because according to
video game chronicles there have been
sources that have come out of konami
that are remaining anonymous because
they don't really have the authority to
speak publicly on these things but seem
to have knowledge about these things
what konami seems to be doing following
the restructuring of their video game
development division earlier this year
is they are looking to basically either
remaster or totally remake a lot of
these video game franchises that they
own metal gear solid silent hill and
truth to tell i feel like this is going
to be highly divisive a lot of people
look at the entire metal gear solid
franchise as being as successful as it
was because hideo kojima was the one who
developed it and seeing konami go back
and basically outsource the
redevelopment remaster or whatever it is
of this game is really going to be
something a lot of hideo kojima fans are
going to take as being offensive now at
the moment it looks like all we're
getting is remasters of metal gear solid
for the playstation and metal gear solid
2 for the playstation 2. of course we'll
probably end up getting remasters of
other games if they even really need
them snake eater i imagine could get a
remaster as well just kind of updated
for next-gen graphics on next-gen
consoles but all this seems to lead into
a bigger metal gear project the big
question to ask here is will anybody be
receptive to it because metal gear goes
hand in hand with hideo kojima and if
he's not the one writing the story he's
not the one basically spearheading the
entire project will it have the same
kind of significance and the same kind
of impact because every bit of news that
we've seen about this and even these
individuals coming out anonymously there
has been nothing to say that hideo
kojima will have any involvement with
this whatsoever and given the very
public and the the huge kind of fallout
between hideo kojima and konami it
doesn't look like he ever will right it
doesn't look like he's going to have any
real big involvement there and as far as
i'm aware kojima is currently working on
a sequel to death stranding which
whether or not you enjoy that game is
really outside the discussion of this
video but i am curious to see what your
girl's take is on this do you guys think
it's okay for konami to go back and
remaster or remake these games that they
have that they basically own even though
they were pioneered and made as
successful as they were by somebody else
or do you guys not like the idea does it
kind of piss you off do you think it
won't necessarily be as good as the
original versions let me know what you
guys think with remasters not
necessarily as bad you're basically
taking the original source material and
just updating it for modern consoles
with remakes this is a whole different
beast so let me know what you guys think
down in the comments section but for
those of you guys out there who are
nickelodeon and avatar fans although how
you're an avatar fan but not a
nickelodeon fan because avatar was made
by nickelodeon we got the release of the
final character for the nickelodeon
all-star brawl which is tough from
avatar the last airbender truth to tell
i'm happy about this but i'm sad about
it at the same time personally i love
tough toff was amazing right she was
just a horse like there was this tick
tock video i saw where they were talking
about when she metal bended for the
first time in combat like you guys
remember that in like the final episode
when like they're all basically invading
like the fire nation blimps essentially
they're like torching the force and
everything and toff goes running up in
there blasts the door off his hinges and
then bonds the door to herself is like a
metal suit and somebody was like here's
this little girl this 12 year old girl
who comes busting into this place and
basically metal bins something that's
never been done before and puts the fear
of god in these guys and they were like
that's the dedication of the firebenders
because even then they're still fighting
there's literally nothing they can do by
the time you got to legend of korra you
didn't really see much of toff but dude
it was kind of cool it was amazing like
i was talking to mirage and i was like
how come nobody picks fights with toff
she's like
because they're smart
they're like she's like tough is a
monster by the time he gets a legend of
korra like she built a whole city right
so i am excited to see toff the funny
thing is i wish i would have seen zuko
having said that we know there's gonna
be dlc characters if i'm being honest
with you guys nickelodeon's gonna
release zuko as a dlc you're gonna have
to pay for that [ __ ] which is kind of
smart because people will pay money to
see zuko and nickelodeon's all-star
brawl the question you have to ask here
is is this going to be zuko who has
presumably mastered the ability to bend
lightning by the time you got into
legend of korra i don't think he's ever
really confirmed whether he did or not
he was able to basically deflect
lightning right to like redirect
lightning in an avatar the last
airbender but we don't know if he
actually mastered at least i'm not aware
that he actually matched it you guys
might know better than i do but the
important thing here is are we gonna see
that version of zuko are we gonna see
zuko as we saw him at the end of avatar
the last airbender because in truth i
think that was the height of his
popularity and i think that if they're
gonna give us zuko in all star brawl
they're gonna give us the most popular
version of the character right they're
not gonna give us the one nobody
wants they're one they're gonna give us
the the zuko at the end of his
redemption arc having said that it would
be cool if we got different skins so you
get like zuko at the beginning of avatar
when he's got like the ponytail he just
he looks amazing i love the way he
looked at the beginning of avatar but
nonetheless maybe we'll get that version
as like a skin or something along those
lines the important thing here is we're
getting tough and that's the end of it
and so as far as the the kind of avatar
roster goes right the characters from
avatar we're getting angry getting core
we're getting tough so we'll probably
end up seeing a lot more of the avatar
roster added in in future dlc but let me
know what you guys think right because
i'm excited about nickelodeon's all-star
brawl i'm hyped about this right i mean
it basically feels like super smash bros
but it's still gonna be cool right it's
gonna be a really really really cool
concept so let me know what you guys
think i'm excited about it now on to our
next bit of news here apparently
amazon's new world is a just breakout
success apparently people absolutely
love it in all honesty i've been holding
off on it because i've got an rtx titan
and i don't want to break a 2500
graphics card so let me know if you guys
think
that it's worth having right is it worth
getting into new world i don't want my
graphics card totally bricked so i've
kind of been holding off on it but i
know some of you guys have probably been
playing it is it a game worth getting
into is it a fun game i might just watch
some youtube videos on i mean i already
have and it did look cool but at the
same time there's a difference between a
game looking cool and a game being cool
a really good example of that is
overkill's the walking dead the trailers
looked cool the game was ass so let me
know what you guys think
is amazon's new world worth getting into
but moving back into our discussions on
the marvel cinematic universe there's a
lot of stuff to kind of unpack here
right so first things first we get 11
deleted scenes from shanghi with the
release of the blue right now before you
guys start freaking out they don't
really look like they're all that
significant it looks like more character
development especially involving razer
fist than anybody else but it's not like
there was a deleted scene where they
have a reference to iron man right or
where like captain america shows up at
some point in time which really kind of
makes sense the movie was designed to
basically be isolated it is an origin
film and so the deleted scenes really
seem to belong more to the individual
characters themselves having said that
if what you were looking for in the
movie was more character development
more relation and interpersonal
development among the characters in the
shang chi film then you will definitely
see that in the deleted scenes which
might be right up your alley but moving
on to our next little discussion here
again that's not a great big huge
talking point let's talk about daredevil
season four slash echo season one so
echo for those of you guys who don't
know is a new series being launched by
disney plus and one of the big things
that a lot of people have kind of seen
as far as rumors go is that daredevil's
getting a season four it is but it kind
of isn't so what it looks like they're
getting here according to daniel rpk
daniel richtman who's a well-known
leaker that a lot of you guys probably
know about is they're taking what would
be the cast of daredevil and they're
initially putting them into the echo
show which seems like it's going to
springboard into a new daredevil season
now in truth this is a smart reason but
not for the reason you think so the
smart decision here is to put these
characters in echo because in all
honesty echo's a new ip right it's a
whole new character that we've never
seen before with disney plus and i think
the smart decision here comes in the
fact that if the first episode isn't
enough to catch people right because we
saw that with juan division if the first
episode or even the second episode
doesn't catch people they leave right
now a lot of those folks who left the
beginning of one division were kicking
themselves by the time he got to the end
because they had to play catch up and
they were left out on just all the
awesome moments that happened over the
course of that show so uh if you're one
of those people i don't know what to
tell you sucks to be you but if echo
doesn't really latch people in it
doesn't bring them in in the first
episode
the cast of daredevil likely will so
it'll be able to kind of keep people on
long enough to sort of get them invested
in the character of echo hopefully but
it also basically tells us these folks
exist in the mcu which is really the big
question a lot of people have been
asking since the netflix shows are no
longer part of the marvel cinematic
universe i mean you really kind of have
to ask the question when jeff lowe was
running the whole thing was it ever part
of the marvel cinematic universe right
because they kept referring to the hulk
as the big green guy and they kept
calling the invasion of new york the
event just these stupid names and we all
basically knew what they were but then
like as time progressed and then once
netflix series were cancelled then it
was like is it even part of the mcu
anymore and then feige was like not
really so like the fact these characters
are coming back basically says yeah man
charlie cox is part of the mcu john
bernthal's punisher who's slated to get
his own series on disney plus is part of
the mcu it's cool to see that they're
all coming back right their name draws
we've been looking forward to them for
quite some time so seeing how they're
introduced in the echo show will give us
a very good indication of what the new
season of daredevil will look like now i
use the phrase daredevil season 4 just
as a placeholder here because in all
honesty i doubt it would be a season
four if anything it would probably be a
relaunch even though we're seeing
characters from the daredevil series
carried over john bernthal's punisher
who appeared in daredevil season two
which was in truth the best season of
daredevil and i don't care what anybody
says but the fact that his character
appeared there and is coming over it
could just be a continuation right maybe
it'll be daredevil season four maybe
it'll just be the daredevil and that's
all they're gonna call it who knows but
regardless we are getting those
characters in the marvel cinematic
universe according to rickman and he
really hasn't been wrong all that often
so i'm inclined to believe this guy but
moving on to our final talking point
here and this is a big one what if
episode 8 as you guys know focus on
ultron basically getting the infinity
gauntlet and then just wreaking havoc
eventually getting into this great big
huge fight with the watcher that
actually saw ultron consuming what was
initially a world and then eventually an
entire galaxy now this has spurred a
massive conversation on social media
among people who were talking about the
practicality of introducing someone like
galactus into the mcu and the stance
people are taking is if ever there were
a time for it to make sense it's now and
the reason why is because galactus even
though we've seen a lot of crazy things
the infinity gauntlet thanos blinking
out half the life in the universe
altering reality when draxler destroyer
and all those guys went to go meet the
collector and it looked like everything
was fine and then it turned out
everything was destroyed we've seen some
cool stuff seeing a guy that's 2 000
feet tall standing on earth assembling a
machine and then consuming it
even then seems a little wild but
everything the marvel cinematic universe
is doing really seems to be going
towards the idea of making that
something that would make sense i mean
in eternals we're getting celestials and
those guys are enormous right those guys
are absolutely huge so seeing these
giant kind of space gods exist having
these beings that are just so
astronomically huge that will likely be
able to alter their size right so as
we'll see them in relation to the
eternals may not even be the true size
that we actually see them as right like
when you go into the movie their head is
the size of the earth i mean what was it
there was that poster that was out there
like literally in that poster i want to
say that like the earth was the size of
like their eyeball right it was they
were just colossal in scale whether or
not we'll actually see them that big i
don't really know but the cool thing
here is that all the stuff that we're
getting the celestials this depiction of
ultron being so big that his head could
consume a galaxy all seems to be going
towards this idea of like lending
credence to galactus so that when we see
a giant guy in a purple suit with what
looks like horns coming out of his head
people are going to be like this is just
getting ridiculous they're going to be
like yeah
galactus
i love seeing to meet world they're
going to be excited about it right i
mean i know i will right but but getting
comic book fans on board is infinitely
easier than getting like a soccer mom or
like a hockey dad on board right like
those guys are just going to be like i
mean this is a little bit of a stretch
man but like by the time after seeing
all this what-if stuff seeing the
eternals by the time i get to the
fantastic four galactus will be an easy
digestion right so that's one of the
things that i love about what the mcu is
doing is everything kind of builds on
everything else not necessarily just in
world building so one thing leads to
another but in this kind of easing in of
just these crazy ass concepts so that by
the time you get to like the crazier
concepts you can accept them
because let's be honest with ourselves
right if we had gone to see like the
first avengers movie and like galactus
just showed up out of nowhere right or
fantastic four had been released after
iron man one and the main villain was
galactus
no
no we would have been on board with it
all right we we would have we would have
been like yeah this is cool
we would have been down with it let's
let's just be honest yeah i mean i would
have right i would have just been like
yeah man this is pretty badass so i
don't know regardless guys let me know
what you think down in the comments
section
[Laughter]
are you excited to see galactus in the
mcu i know i am because as we know it's
only a matter of time he's coming right
galactus is coming there's no way that
the mcu starts with iron man 1 ends with
whatever movie they make and we never
see galactus along the way right and i
can bet you bottom dollar he's not going
to be some giant cloud with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end thank you guys for watching and i
will catch you all later peace